i'm muted because we're ordering style
books right now just give me a second oh
okay
and i'll have a um grande
mocha frappa crappie
grande caramel creme brulee
sprinkles because i'm feeling naughty
the american starbox options are amazing
have you ever done a transformer troy
you haven't done a track yeah
i've done two i've done yeah i've done
two
a transformer sounds very uh in like
full of cybertron actually three i did
three i did jazz which probably
shouldn't have happened
yeah it's good
bold okay
but here's how it happened what even is
down the hall
huh what even is that that escaped my
life
a transformer who is traditionally
voiced uh by african-american actors
originated by scat man for others
yeah so so there have not been a
transformers nerd
clearly oh man my first transformer was
a g1 jet fire
so i was down the hall
recording on something else and they
said
can you do scat man carruthers and i was
like
i need more context should i
for what you mean and so just kind of on
i was like
sure and what i really was doing if
anybody knows
was bubs
from homestar runner
and and so they went great i was like
what just happens like you just got a
gig don't worry about it we'll do it
later and i came in and they told me i
was doing jet fire i was like
oh my gosh you got to do jet fighters
like yeah you remember the audition you
did i was like no
and like remember we i came into the
room and you just did a little bit of
jazz i was like guys like you're playing
jazz like oh i don't know if we should
be doing this or not and we did it twice
but i also got to do jet fire which was
which was just so it's kind of like a a
good payoff
whatever but then that studio folded
uh and the game was not good um it was
not but and and then i got to do it for
an actual proper show and i got to be
like the baddie
it was awesome so very cool
yeah
troy i don't think i've ever asked
before have you ever had like a dream
role like a dream character that you've
always wanted to play
everyone i ever get
oh um
yeah i mean obviously then fits that
list
never let it go
i mean if you feed me if you feed me a
setup that effectively everyone i get
here's some soft pitch ready yeah
exactly austin eyes on the ball here we
go i am not above the soft pair it is
um so
yeah i got to i got to do i mean batman
was my first graphic novel i ever got
and i got to do that and then i got to
be the joker which was
really the kind of the role that
that made me go i want to
do this but i never thought that i would
do joker i just i just thought that i i
wanted to do that
and i felt it was very i may have said
this to you guys before um by the way
it's not nine o'clock in the morning
i was going to say i love this
listeners
i'm learning amazing
normally we all have cups of coffee
uh alana pierce is getting her cup of
coffee in transit
yeah pasta wintry of course has his but
that doesn't matter cause you it could
be six o'clock at night and you're
having a cup of coffee oh i had one
i'd do that too i had i had
espresso
like when we when we recorded last time
i think it was ten o'clock for us and i
made one for the show
and uh
so yeah i was i can't relate at all to
that i can't relate to something yeah
exactly
i no but mike bethel you know you know
the day he's had by his beverage so
that's true that's true uh this this is
this is kind of
you never have tea
as a fruit you never have tea
i'm often drinking tea on the show it's
always assumed because of your americans
just don't tell us it's coffee sometimes
just you know to fit better with the
crowd you know you're you're with
americans you don't want to have to
explain tears again it's you know
sometimes
you go with the flow
you don't want to defend your dirt water
and get it exactly yeah a lot of teeth
yeah
yeah so it's a beverage absolutely no
bad history as well which is great
wasn't doubt water like
a working title for that robin williams
moving they were like it doesn't have
the same kind of punch to it like doubt
earth
fifth element fire
[ __ ]
um
you won't forget anyway
i was there
someone someone hopefully will
appreciate that i i yeah they'll like it
they'll like that i'll play well in the
comments as long as none of us mention
nfts we'll be fine
did anybody watch the south park special
coveted coveted special i still haven't
despite your protestation i oh my god
how did you not there was nothing else
for you to do
you know that's the thing that's that's
the that's the thing that's so what else
to do
i just like to make very clear i'm a fan
of wine troy i think that's uh that's a
good new thing for the show mike can we
please go whining
oh
is that what this [ __ ] i feel like i
feel like we whine every week troy i
feel like we won every week w-h-i-n-e
hey how about when we go to vegas then
then uh there's there's a one there's a
couple places but there's there's one
place oh you want to go to the place
where the wall would be like this was
like an elephant yeah i know exactly
let's do that are you into wine alana is
it your thing i'm sorry what yeah i like
wine i i i have a lot of trouble
drinking red because it gives me a
headache so
do you drink california's
this is gonna be guys you probably
should just tune out i heard that like
double tap on the right side of the
screen for youtube and and fast forward
a couple of times and then audio
listeners this is probably where an ad
is going to come in i don't know
um
alana do you drink california reds
i couldn't even tell you i've been so
scared off of red that i don't really
drink it at all all right if you go old
world if you do like some some french or
italian
easy peasy whole world
that did hold mines it's like
i have a video game question i haven't
been here can i give context for us tell
everyone what's going to play with this
and i don't want a ps9
because
um
i'm currently in colorado because i want
to to spend like a couple of days in the
woods doing hikes in boulder so i'm
driving to boulder i was hoping to be
there but flight got delayed so i'm not
um that's austin wintery none of the big
pointing works can you do it this way
here's the video i gave him close about
mike double he's a video game director
announcer he's a video game actor look
at us go what's the question and wine
expert not really
well i'd buy it on the show yeah
i know i know a little bit i've i've
like educated myself a little bit
um i know like one region and that's
that's about it i know enough what was
the video game question
so i i started and i never finished so i
just finished or in the blind forest
i'm the switch
did it almost switch that definitive
edition
got that plot
nice
feeling good about it
uh it's been i mean there's there's very
few games that i will 100 completionist
you know get get all of it but it was
like what what's that i can't remember
now what it says uh i took a picture of
it but it's like a guardian of the
forest or whatever and i was like damn
[ __ ] straight i am i took that little
white [ __ ] and flipped them all around
that forest
oh my
god
my favorite part was was pam and i were
um
on the flight so i had the aisle
traveler was on the middle and then she
was on the other middle so it was like a
one two one configuration of how we were
flying and so she couldn't see me all
she could see with my hands and so she
would just kind of see just this
just like
shaking
frustration i i yield a lot of these
very hard games
they are they are
but here's here's my question so i i
literally just finished and i i finished
the game
though if you haven't finished the games
it's really really it's a beautiful
beautiful poem
uh the design is is those people i want
to meet all of them and then punch them
in the dick
just
um you know that that team met in person
for the first time ever at their launch
party awards
or was that the launch part i thought it
was at the awards yeah like they all
were like desperate 100 remote studio
uh
from conception
i was cruising the desires also 100
remote obviously a bit different because
some of them are siblings
but a lot of the rest of their studio is
completely remote and
uh
cuphead
no way
see what happens offices are expensive
troy but yeah but put put people
together and they'll make a less
challenging game
like i don't ever want to see like
like from software go we're all going to
go remote like [ __ ] you no no no no no
no
that'll be too hard
i i think i i was cursing their design
because i was like this is broken like
this is too challenging it's too hard
but i never quit the game and that's
really i i will i will bail on a game if
it's if it doesn't grab me if it doesn't
have
the
if it's too challenging for me then i'll
bail
i just don't get to play it as much as i
want to and so when i play i don't want
it to be that punishing
but i finished it all the way and so i
immediately started playing
um will the wisps and have you ever had
a game where you love the fur and i
think it's super ironic that of all
people i'm bringing this up but have you
ever played a game that you loved the
first one
[Music]
and then the sequel came and even though
you could tell
there was i mean there's all new systems
that they included in this there's
there's a definite elevation and an
upgrade it's not just a new map i
already have my answer to this question
all right go knights of the old republic
uh
in every in every way from a gameplay
standpoint the second one is an
improvement and yet i think the first
one is my preferred of the two why
because if nothing else it told a more
interesting story that felt somehow more
at home with
the nature of the mechanics and the you
know the bioware dialogue trees and you
spend so much time listening to
characters and i felt that what they had
to say was
what it added up better even though i
liked that the second one was going in
the direction of
you know moral quandaries in the in the
world of star wars which is not as
typical you know it was usually star
wars was typically a little bit more
good in evil black and white and the
second one i'll never forget towards the
beginning the second one had this
moment where
there was like uh there was like a
street you know like a like a beggar on
some planet and if you gave them money
they immediately ran off and got killed
because they had money or something like
that and it was supposed to be this it
can't remember exactly but something
along those lines where it was sort of
like you know the downstream effects of
what seems like a good action may not be
a good action and but it didn't go as
many places as i was hoping it was going
to go i'm not sure that that's the point
where you want to try to teach that
lesson
don't give the homeless money i feel
like maybe you could choose a different
they can't be responsible with it it was
something it was something and well the
truth is you know take it with a grain
of salt that was exact the setup but it
was one of those things where
you know you had this kind of shadowy
figure i can't remember her name but she
was kind of like a maybe is she a sith
maybe is she a jedi there were a lot of
things that i thought this is
to be really great and but they had
definitely improved like the combat and
from a design standpoint it's and even
just visually everything about it was a
step up and yet when i think back
on that franchise the first one is the
one that i just go man knights of the
old republic one of the great rpg you
know one of those great bioware one of
my hands down favorite i actually agree
with you swatter coder yeah
mine's uh fable i love the first people
um including the anniversary which is
like the extended version of the first
fable i do not like fable two or three i
still finished them
um but in comparison they feel like kids
games it's not that favor one wasn't
obviously i played it when i was a kid
but it i think that combat is a little
bit
more mature in a really weird way or
maybe the first one is more mature
yeah the combat is yeah
and i think like you know
after the second game came out they had
the connect game it just felt like the
audience was changing and it was almost
to me like microsoft was like oh this is
our like flagship kid game and i have no
idea if that's correct
um but the first one like definitely had
mature jokes and like sexual references
and all that um
i love that game but i don't like the
second or third that said
troy a lot of people agree with you on
re1 and 2. i preferred the second one
and i think the reason i prefer it is
because it's clearly inspired by hollow
knight it has a lot of similar systems
to hollow knight which came out in
between those two games and i love that
um but a lot of people agree like that
they prefer the first one over the
second one or vice versa
it's something that is very true to you
know
i mean we saw the same thing with the
last of us it's like last of us is a
very simple game it's a simple story
simple mechanics the stuff that's
happening under the hood for those
paying attention is is pretty cool
but there were even like with the ai it
was an intentional choice to make sure
that like
ellie behaved in a specific way that
wouldn't you know their people could
complain that was like ellie would get
you into trouble like well yeah but
we could either do one of two things and
that neil and and and jacob minkoff and
all those guys could explain this far
better than i but it came down to a
choice of like what do we want to do
here with this ai system
and do we want to do so when we get to
part two
there's there's a whole new you know
bucket of lego to play with so to speak
and so
you don't just want to go well we told
that story let's tell it again
you elevate everything i get it but
there was just something and maybe it's
coming off of if if i'd give it some
time there's very few things that you
want to go you don't want to go watch
lord of the rings one two and three back
to back other people have it's like
get up from the couch for a second and
just like
breathe for a second
but there was something about it that
going from being super powerful having
all of the abilities and all of them
maxed out to then the reduction of that
i'm like oh my god like i had forgotten
and i played i put 23 hours into that
game so there's more people that had
like 10 15 hours i i really really took
my time and there was a lot of stuff
that was probably more challenging than
it was for most
but
i think that
going from such a and when you when
you're fully maxed out on something it's
so enjoyable because you go back to all
the old enemies that you used to and
you're like [ __ ] you you just do
whatever you want and then coming back
to the most basic of jumps or the most
basic of enemies
and you don't have all those things so
it's interestingly yeah the last of us
part two does that within its own game
don't define
to losing
your upgrades um
in a way that i actually at first was
like oh this feels weird i just got so
used to that but i ended up really
liking it because it gives you a very
good idea of
in terms of design pairing with the
narrative of those characters being in
different places
um and also communicated but it does do
the same thing it communicated so much
about the design intent because when
the first time i realized that the kind
of upgrade tree or whatever it was
however of abby
as soon as i because i kept thinking
this is like a five minute vignette and
so i
i wasn't like playing as as you know
seriously as as it were you know you
play with a certain reckless quality
because you're not feeling like you're
investing and as soon as the game
communicated you know you actually are
investing it it all it took was a brief
display of that ui and i completely
reoriented my
gameplay approach immediately which i
thought was such an interesting like
that's a that's that's a narrative
uh and and gameplay communication tool
that is so unique to this medium that it
all it took was the display of that and
realizing oh [ __ ] i just reset the whole
clock
but i feel you my uh on this just to
insert an additional thought on re2 it's
funny because i had
i think i had i guess the sort of
mainstream opinion then because i didn't
realize this i assumed everybody liked
the second one better
because it was definitely one of those
where it seemed like
everything about it was an improvement
and yet i still also
liked the first one but i realized it
was because the second one
i would almost liken it to this is a
unfair comparison because it's it's
better so don't explode but
it's kind of like
the relationship of the matrix to its
sequels where
they
once they realized that they had
something special you talk about the new
one because that is a compliment
you haven't seen it
no
guys wait troy pause oh i was making a
point
i also haven't seen the sequel i've been
in no rush when i've seen the dog piling
of of hatred for it i
love it
i love it i did see spider-man though
which impressed the hell out of me but
so um so uh all i was gonna say is
the the problem that the second and
third one fell into is that once they
kind of
became so aware of what they had it it
flooded with over-indulgence uh and and
you might like the new one you might
like when you are based entirely on that
sentence
yeah i'm yeah i i really have extremely
low expectations but the but the the the
ori timmy had that same problem it was
like all the conciseness and tightness
of the first one the fact that it said
so like troy you described it as being
like a poem and i i largely agree with
that i felt like some of the narrative
bits especially the beginning were so
ham-fisted that it i couldn't not roll
my eyes but the but the the the general
uh poetic nature of it for sure and the
second one suddenly all the like npcs
have names and backstories and all that
and i was like
that it's like they realized oh
now we've got this super awesome ip
let's go nuts with it and i was like
yeah but that's not really what ori is i
would argue i am not one it's not my
also
that's also the thing i think i saw this
point now by someone one so so
i think all of us have had this
experience at some point in our careers
but like
i remember when when when mate thomas
was alone
and it blew up in the way it did
um i definitely
made thomas was alone and it blew up
yeah
we've all we've all had we've all had
the thing that will be engraved on our
gravestones no matter what we do
after right i definitely had the time
read a lot of stuff about
uh sophomore success or like one hit
wonders or that kind of that whole field
of like
this the difficult second album
basically because i knew i was riding
towards a difficult second album
inevitably right like just because it
was going to be the way it was and one
of the most interesting things i read on
that which i definitely took to heart
having made it easier when i made
subsequent games you know and not every
game i've made has been the the scale of
thomas was alone um was this the the
insight that
uh the first thing you make that is a
hit
has so much more going for it than you
will ever have with any of your
subsequent works a because
it's the thing you've probably worked on
the longest either consciously or
unconsciously it's all the things
everything you've been like wanting to
say with a piece of work everything
you've been building up over your
lifetime of your childhood over your
working life it's kind of your big
opening statement and it's had so much
time you see these bands all the time in
the case of bands it's the stuff you've
been playing in bars on and off for
years that you've kind of been honing
your style with your band mates you've
been working all this stuff out it's all
existed in this big kind of loop for so
long
and also then is selected by the
audience rather than you so you make the
thing and if you happen to be the thing
that blows up you didn't make that thing
blow up that thing blew up because that
was the thing everyone else did yeah
exactly and then with a sequel with a
sequel or a second project a you're
usually under time pressure because
we've got to get more out while the
while going is good b
you're now the selector so everything
that you decide should be in the next
the next game in your franchise or the
next thing you produce
is going to be in there and the audience
don't get to decide what is it isn't a
hit
um
and then of course you've got those
crashing expectations so it was
something that i read i remember reading
that after thomas was alone and thinking
that's a really good framework to
understand what's about to happen to me
um and it
really did help me there's a great
corollary to that for whether or not
you're fans of coldplay or not you know
they
that is there there's a i think uh
specify a perfect example of
that specific story so here's a band
that
was plugged away
and they put out this album called
parachutes
and one song
goes bananas
and they went from nobody to overnight
success
and
they
there's there's songs on that record
that were demos from other like eps that
they put out they just ended up throwing
on and and exactly we were talking about
chris martin had spent so long writing
that record and some of those songs came
to him very quickly he was walking
through hyde park and it's like um we
live in a beautiful world was written
through hyde park there's some there's
some cool stories to it and then all of
a sudden
now they're a big hit and their a rep
goes
all right guys time for that follow-up
and chris martin almost quit because
he's like i i've i have no other songs i
don't think i could ever write another
song again much less something that's
going to top
yeah
anything that comes up for that that
first record
and he called his uh his best friend i
think it's his best friend who was the
drummer if i remember correctly and said
you're not going to believe it
i just wrote the entire album overnight
it was like a sudden rush of blood to
the head
and that's where that entire album and
that album became far more successful
than than the first one so i i think
that there are certain examples where i
i i really want to come in and i hope
everyone at moon studios understands
that i am in no way disparaging the game
i'm talking about again i'm still
playing it literally it's right in front
of me right here
i'm i'm i'm struggling with it because
something that i spent so long on and
grew to love and wrestled with and was
and was um
i had challenges both i was like do i
continue this game i quit it twice
because i was like i'm just not going to
do this anymore and i was even speaking
to to someone who worked on
uh
will the wisp and then we're like you
really need to get through it's like
where are you at i was like i'm in four
lone runes she's like you're so close
i'm like ah so i came back to it i
didn't even i loved it i didn't even
feel like it had any slobs like i really
really enjoyed it
um
gravity it's like come on man just
there's fire and gravity and
i really actually i liked the mechanics
that were introduced were really clever
they thought they really built it
built nicely i just it was
it was bloated from a narrative and kind
of world building standpoint but the
gameplay was a
to me yeah the really clever
i remember the kind of blue grass that
you hook into where there's these
puzzles of the rotating wheels that you
have to kind of slingshot off of and i
remember thinking this is
and you know the other thing that they
did so unbelievably with that is
their optimization of that uh where you
it's it's the least punishing gameplay
loop i think i've ever experienced where
your your instant respawn
you know and smooth continuation of
gameplay where it's really hard but it
feels like reiterating is such a
continuous and fast process that you're
never like comparatively to the first
one yes because though they both both
had that because i remember playing the
first one relatively
close to cuphead and it couldn't have
been more opposite gameplay experiences
for me where cuphead is like
brutally difficult and then you you die
and it it pulls up the loading screen
and then the music restarts from from
from the beginning again and it's like
everything about it whereas one you know
like one of the things that i i thought
they did really nicely here was that so
much of the world is continuous like
garrett my of course
compulsory uh shout out to my friend uh
gareth coker for the great scores the
musical games beautiful the music is
beautiful yeah he uh you know they make
it so that music basically doesn't ever
stop you know it's like if unless i'm
somehow remembering it wrong where you
know you die and and there's a sense
that the world is continuing
and you respawn and it's not that the
game is doing a hard reboot based on
your death you're just kind of
reappearing and that made it so
palatable to die a thousand times right
but with ori with blind forest
saving your game was a mechanic
it wasn't just a feature
so i would intentionally save i choose
my save point versus now the game
chooses for me
you know what i mean yeah still but but
i just mean the the sheer
the sheer turnaround time between the
ability to try again just that sure the
tiny window of that regardless of even
if i have to run to go back over to
where i was and it's you know a little
ways off screen or what just the fact
that i'm not on a loading screen is the
reason that i think it's the single
yeah that's the reason why i never gave
up on that game i found it continuously
enjoyable because the friction was
almost non-existent
and that's a huge win for a platformer
that's what gets that's how they can get
away with something that's
so hard because it's such a joy you just
try again one second later like it's a
super meat boy trick right it works
every time yeah
yeah
that's a funny picture of this this
leading us down a path of um though i
feel like i should ask two questions
first uh first troy how have you of all
people not seen the matrix yet
dude okay so
it's a it's the holidays man and i've
i've barely been here
like i went from a dead stop no travel
to first of november to the end of the
year i flew about 80 000 miles so like i
daddy got in the air
so
i i just haven't i haven't had my my ass
on the ground much less in the seat of a
of a movie theater so i definitely this
this week is is what i'm planning on
doing that there's you can catch it
streaming by the way i watched it on
hdmx
i don't i know you i know i can it feels
it feels wrong it feels wrong um it's
like having a really hot cousin it's
like yeah but you can
[Laughter]
i did want to do it it is exactly the
same as that
go and talk to
mike did you have a pick for a game
where you really um preferred the the
first of these yeah
i have a second to third can i do that
is that with me yes i feel like that is
isn't that everybody with mass effect
they well so that means
it's it's it's
it's a troy joint but it's not the troy
joy that you'd expect um it's some and
it definitely falls under the counter
the exact same category of objectively
the third is better than the second but
i did not like it as much it's metal
gear solid like i really like for me
mgs2 is like the pinnacle of series and
there's like three of us who think this
way um we are we are very rare because
three is objectively the better game
it's it's richer it's more interesting
it's a lot of things but something about
two i think when i tried to sit down and
work it out i think for me with two it
was
the constraint of the location i really
like two has that die hard feel it feels
like a very specific piece of geography
that you're interacting with that you're
working with
really kind of comic booky
well one's excellent as well but two two
is better than three because
for me three feels a bit too wide open
and it lost oh
opinion i think most people would say
one to two
i think definitely the view at the time
was that two was
great mechanically but a bit of a set
down in terms of like story everyone
hated ryden back in the day it's worth
remembering that wasn't kind of a secret
right going into it yeah um it was kind
of the the first big like trailer lie
um i'd be fascinating to see how that
would play out now wait i don't remember
this what was the trailer life
so every trailer for mel gets solid 2
pretended that snake was the main
character of the game spoilers for melee
side so i suppose
there's trailers if you go back to like
the mgs2 trailers they show snake in all
of the scenarios that you then play as
uh as him as ryden um and everyone hated
ryden
um there was
weird homophobia attached to that in the
community there was some weird kind of
gung-ho-ness i guess or kind of a desire
for kind of the grizzled more uh
more 80s action hero kind of vibe of
snake which is pretty good
yes but i think there was less nuance to
the discussion than that um and you've
seen that crop up and you see like like
those
is it literally like a character called
raidonovich in three right he's like the
gay lover of one of the bad guys like
there was definitely like some weird
stuff buzzing around around right but i
loved ryden and the joy i felt when
revengeance was announced because he was
always like
i remember when they came out
i remember being at e3 and seeing that
demo and then seeing the name it was
called revengeance i was like how has no
one thought of that name
why is there not 50 80s movies called
revengeance i think probably because
even the executives in the 80s were like
it's a big month yeah
that's too far that's too far
we may be in the 80s and doing coke in
our boardrooms but we are like
excuse me
i'll do it [ __ ] it i'll do it
so my leading question off of all of
this is going to be
i like the idea of off of troy gushing
about blind forest
if everyone has a pick for what their
favorite game they played this year was
but it doesn't have to be a game that
came out this year
or i could make it that it can't be
oh man
my favorite game that i played this year
i'll go was link's awakening original on
on the og on on the little gameboy right
there
and i just downloaded it for my switch
too because i want to see how different
it is but that's because i i started
that game when i was you know 12.
and i finally just got to finish it
thanks again you only just finished it
wait we may have spoken about this
already i don't remember yeah eric
castro hungry bartender hooked me up
with the original game boy
and i i plugged that [ __ ] in and i put
in the hours and i cried like i got to
the very end i was like i've been
waiting
you know 35 years sort of 33 years
whatever to to finish this game and and
it's just that's the i know everyone's
talking about the pocket coming out and
it's it's all in the the hoopla and
everyone's really excited about it and i
i really um
i think playing any game especially the
games that have inspired and
have sired the amount of game designers
that we have today i think it's it's
helpful to understand it's the same
thing as history understanding history
going back and reading classics and
watching old movies you know that was
like that's stupid i mean you need to
understand
you need to watch coppola's movies in
the 70s you need to watch
uh brian de palma's movies in the 70s to
understand the filmmakers that are
making movies now and it helps put that
into a different lens and i think
everything helps
bring about some more empathy so that i
could be a little bit more compassionate
towards the people trying to [ __ ] me
in
the mine forest
is because they played games like
castlevania and metroid and everything
growing up and now they want to do
something that has those mechanics but
reframe that
in a in a more palatable and modern way
right there can be a flip side to that
though i i agree um
and i definitely think the ori is
but wasn't it citizen came where people
were like how did you make this movie
and he was like i just didn't know the
rules i didn't know any better so i just
made something
i think that there could be something
he's like i'm gonna make the last of us
of movies
the rules and making something i feel
like you've come out i don't believe
that's different i don't believe that's
true i i think that is totally true
it's one of those things that works one
percent of the time but one percent of
the time it works really well you 100
knew the rules by the way there's no one
that could have understood like he went
he had been invented in the business
yeah he invented most of them he he was
so
unscrupulous
and true why are you to like not be
obeying rules like to be able to invent
something new in filmmaking you have to
be like [ __ ] your established rules i
love can i just point out for a moment
how happy i am that we've utterly
derailed the lana's expert approach of
trying to make the uh to be fair i think
i like the youtube
100
you went for that youtube our games of
the year title for the episode
troy comes out of the world with a game
that came out two years ago in a sequel
that came out whenever
and then it's like ah [ __ ] that's not
relevant how do we
citizen kane that's always good what
what gets good tracking of
john madden um
i just think that our favorite games of
the year is a good headline i think it's
just uh wholesome i like the idea of
like taking time to talk about games
that you like that aren't trending you
know
you know what like oh that's like great
games journalism by the way this is
great games journalism
well i was i'm a games journalist i
still i still would put um i would still
put inscription as probably my favorite
release of the year i'm still working
through a bunch of titles but nothing
has nothing is dethroned although i
still haven't finished it because i had
to pause it in order to keep plowing
through my list because i i there's you
know i'm on i'm on some juries where i i
have to i have to log some hours on on a
bunch of games oh god but i think the
dominated description i think the um
i think the um
um
the
the ironic thing is you got mass effect
austin
i mean that the funny thing is that that
probably did bring me the most happiness
just because i just haven't bottomless
well of
of happiness
like reactivity to that to that game and
and um and god damn do i just love
so much uh
you know i could replay them it's almost
an annual
it's kind of like every 18
to 20 months or so
i i kind of just compulsively replay the
mass effect trilogy and so but doing so
again this time felt special because of
the legendary edition but the funny
thing is
for reasons i will explain on this show
later in future episodes you know it was
in london uh uh until just a few days
ago
and due to covet related uh mania i
ended up sort of
you know quarantined in a hotel room for
five days hence when we recorded last
time
uh and um although i didn't get covid
but anyway i'll i'll illuminate all that
later but
it's such a it's such a like to be stuck
in a room you know that's a
one-fifth the size of this room
uh and has you know
windows i can't open that only just look
at a brick wall and and like to just
kind of be in this time warp of i don't
know when is when and everybody i know
is eight hours time difference away and
like you just enter into this bazaar so
i i had my laptop with i had this you
know couple years old macbook
laptop and i thought
i wonder what i have that in my steam
library that's compatible with this
computer and as it turned out xcom 2 ran
just fine so i played like 40 [ __ ]
hours of xcom 2 over the last no way and
i have to say that is truly one of the
best games i [ __ ] love that franchise
in general but it was such a cathartic
way to get through
the uh the covid uh score hold on hold
on hold on so that may be my winner for
2021.
how did you do that though what do you
mean the mac because it's a laptop
it i mean it it's the the build is on
steam is compatible with with mac and
the laptop is just powerful enough to
run a 2017 game so it's right but i'm
just i'm trying to figure out like what
was your like literally the the input
because you're not controller you're not
keyboard mouse
i mean it's
not needed
right yeah no yeah it's just all you
need is a mouse right click
yeah i guess yeah it's really yeah that
that's that's actually specifically why
i chose it because i i had there were a
bunch of games that showed up but
anything first person is a complete
non-starter without any kind of mouse or
something and so i i was like this plus
i've just i mean like my steam library
over the course because i've replayed
that game especially once they released
war of the chosen which is what i was
playing you know of course on the iron
man mode which is simultaneously one of
the best and worst things that you could
do it's amazing how incredibly rage
inducing a bad decision can make when
there's zero ability to kind of recover
from it but um
according to steam i've put 154 hours
lifetime total into xcom
which is probably my single highest hour
count of any you know i mean mass effect
as a trilogy probably beats that but
um i want to see but yeah so that was
ironically that may have been my gaming
highlight of 2021
but uh but my official answer is
probably some kind of weird toss-up
between mass effect and inscription
inscription is loud it is it is so good
i i
i'm sure i've said it before on the show
because that's why you've played it i
think but i want to recommend everyone
tries it even if you don't like card
games do not be off put by the fact that
it looks like a card game
because it it goes in directions that
you will not expect it's brilliant um
it's also pretty good like card game for
non-card game people in many ways i
agree it is also a really good card
because i'm not huge into deck building
games i like them but it's not my
favorite i play them at a lower rate
than the rest but i was instantly into
it it was pretty approachable too i felt
like they did a really good job at
onboarding you into the
you know so good
so
austin
shadow award just on this
computer right so not because i
originally played it on
xbox 165 hours
see the funny thing is the only game
i've ever worked on that i was that i
could actually for whatever reason the
only game of mine that i've ever been
able to play like a gamer where i just
somehow found myself enjoying it and not
constantly distracted by my kind of
wincing at all the things i wish i had
done differently musically was the
banner saga and i probably do have close
to that number of hours on that for
whatever reason again maybe what it is
is the turn based strategy but i i i
yeah that that's one where i probably
have
150 hours it's hard to say though
because it's a trilogy and they each one
is
has a different hour account but the
yeah
on hell's highway i i i um
i'm just going through like my
the i remember once you're on my stream
i remember once someone telling me about
a site where you log in your steam
credentials and it tells you the
at the amount of time like all the games
you've not launched yet in your library
how many hours it will take you to play
just the ones finished
and then and then an existential crisis
yeah but then it also tells you other
things that could be done in that same
amount of time where it's like master a
new language and or like you know
it was yeah they've wasted your life it
tells me how long i've put into games
like i usually have that offline so that
i can't see it
solitary conspiracy 27 hours
nice oh nice good choice good choice
erotica 8.7 hours i played the [ __ ] out
of that one who says what are you doing
sorry i apologize that's just that's
just hit me that's a four-hour game you
play for 27 hours 27 hours is that just
playing like the free play mode
um i don't know i've unlocked 14 out of
20 of the achievements
i think what that means is that one of
the times you like went to dinner and
forgot it was right that's probably it's
i remember there was a bug on um
on assassin's creed black flag i
remember there was a remember how in
that game there was uh the the the thing
where you could send ships to like yeah
the new world and that i have that that
game has my highest play time because
it's because of that right
yes exactly same over 400 here too
because it was the bug
kept it's like the game kept running in
the background yeah and and steam
thought you were still playing it even
if the computer was [ __ ] off
and so it was like 440 hours when i
worked at xbox they would print us all
like lanyards for events that would be
like just your your name and i don't
know what your job title was but they
would also put the game that you would
put the most time into and hours played
mine was assassin's creed black flag
there were a bunch of other people's
everyone's like wow good job assassin's
creed no no no no no no no no it's a big
game rules
i'm actually checking right now to see
what my actual number is because i
remember i think mine was 440. i
probably still have the lanyard
somewhere
409 here nice
um what a great thing to go back through
my whole game you played the question
what was your favorite gaming experience
this year i think me yeah mike bethel
yeah
uh it might be hitman three for me i i
[ __ ] love their friends that was fun
that didn't come out but it is a great
game god it feels like really that was
good
it came out this year come on january i
googled it came out january yeah it's um
yeah i'm really excited to play it and
be all right
i don't know if i want to play i'm
excited to see if i would i'm really
excited about it
i mean i don't know
yeah i i just i that that trilogy i
think as well for me especially like
hitman definitely feels
it feels like a franchise that's being
made for me and about 10 000 other
people in the world and there's a magic
to that like it feels very niche
it doesn't feel interesting i mean
that's backed up by the the kind of the
business history of the franchise and
stuff like it doesn't feel like one it
almost feels like a game that shouldn't
really be allowed to exist but doesn't i
kind of love that like there's a magic
to
right
yeah it's not like it is but i know what
you're saying two excellent
movies
yeah so it's in terms of in terms of the
games like they have they've been
they've had mixed levels of success like
for sure like they've definitely been
smaller in that sense but yeah this
feels this trilogy feels like it it just
it feels it feels like a return to form
it also just felt like they started
making games there's a definitely with a
lot with especially with the um oh gosh
absolution the one that came before it
like there you know they were trying to
broaden the audience and these this
trilogy felt like a complete is that the
one with the nuns
absolutely i think it was yeah it was
the one where it was very it was very
corridor shootery they just kind of
tried to pull it in everything but like
the this trilogy feels like yeah it's a
swing in the opposite direction of just
let's make the perfect
what is it the second or third level of
hitman 3 the murder mystery and the text
is like yeah yeah man that's good
so good um and then but then also just
kind of what's really interesting with
three i think this is more true of three
than the other two
is the diversity of like
basically the way in which each of the
levels of that game absolutely
distills a different version of why that
game is good i might i'm the detective
level's my favorite as well but
chatting to a a friend of mine about
that and like his he's much more about
the sandbox so for him berlin is like
the best and everything else in that
game songs and it's interesting that
like there is a there's not sucks but
what's in up to that standard it's it's
fascinating that we live in a very
binary world
amazing
but what's cool is
human is in binary that's what's cool
about it is that even with something
that specific and that it's such a
specific
dish or such a specific ingredient those
specific mechanics even within that it
feel felt like hitman 3 did a great job
of kind of how far can we push that and
how much range can we get out of that
and as someone who constantly has to try
and work out like okay how are we going
to make these 10 mechanics fun for five
hours like that's
i admire that when i see game designers
pulling that off so well as that game
does so yeah really cool i want to point
out the fact
that
i was the one who brought up video games
and we have stayed on [ __ ] target
troy
i think i'm the solution guys
you know
yeah if it makes you feel that's a great
way of looking at it and
if you look at also the comments people
are like wow look at that troy's been
gone and they're still wavering i was
like see
it wasn't just me between now and our
next uh episode so the book of boba fett
will come out so we can make a nice
return to form to arguing about star
wars
no orders saying that we'll talk about
it and not talk about it though i would
also love to talk about matrix um
it's got the best joke ever in it and no
one i've seen online has noticed it but
it's killing me
and i i am totally down really hard and
i don't remember what it was
did you guys see
the new
spider-man
no yeah yes
troy yeah
guys
i have been you need to get out less
troy you need to get out of here as a
child i made a point of seeing it
because
i thought it's a movie that benefits
from trying to dodge the the spoilers uh
and so i i was like i will see it at the
earliest time
like yeah that's uh yeah that's what
that's difficult
i got to fly after two years i mean
traveler was off and running when he was
born like he he's been to london twice
he's been to ireland you say he's a
traveler
that's i mean i wanted him to live up to
his name oh my god
it's been a huge bummer that that he's
not been able to you know travel at all
so i'm glad that we got to go back to
his identity was stricken out of
yeah
they were they would they austin they
were considering renaming him to
stationery yeah exactly
traveller
[Music]
so
oh you guys are born the [ __ ] out of me
um i just yawn that's why i said that
i always do that's the best thing to say
um
i i will i'll also tell you there's
there's another great thing that i got
to do this weekend that's that's that's
super fun to do um
but i was glad that i got to be able to
to travel with my boy and he crushed it
had his own seat and everything he was
just kicked back living his best life it
was awesome
um
but
there's something that i love to do and
i encourage
anybody that has done anything of note
the word to where the public audience
might be able to recognize you
whenever they go
you look
familiar how do i know you which is just
the weirdest question ever it's like i
don't know how you would know me i don't
know anything i always say that's just
my face
that's a great response here's what i do
they're like
are you an as i am interchangeable with
all other blondes so it's a common area
exactly it's it's a slow pull right
because you don't want it you don't want
to just pull this too fast right you
need to you need to let the line out and
let the mat get the fish with his mouth
part on it i've got to tell you i one
time spoken like a proper i've had
people say that to me um i remembered so
distinctly one time in sydney because i
was so angry the guy came up to me was
like i know you from somewhere and i was
like oh okay and so i wait because i
think that he does and it was just a
pickup attempt
i'll sit there and be like cool so like
homie got no game
he's like no i don't i say this they go
they're like [ __ ] trick me i'm an
actor they're like okay
where you look so familiar what would i
know you're from it's like i i don't
know i mean what would you it's like i i
just you i know that i know you from
somewhere and i was like yeah like what
do you do is like i do a lot of porn
uh and they're like oh no and i was like
yeah i mean
it's really weird because i do like like
the worst most of it's illegal um almost
exclusively ever it's like if you you
got to work really hard what would you
know me from and they're like oh no i
want it it's backpedaling it's
super fun to do that's mean
um
experience the opposite i've experienced
the opposite of that where i didn't
recognize a porn star and she was a
little bit like surprised offended by it
that's happened to me wow it's also good
on you
i had a porn star that was my parachute
and star or my my skydiving instructor
once that was fun oh cool so there's a
career pivot the first time i had hummus
uh it was a porn star who was like you
should have hummus and i was like i've
never had it before and she was like
please try the hummus
so you know there's a burst for
everything
just passing i have no porn star stories
i feel i feel out of this come on i said
you live in los angeles
yes i'm in the valley exactly yeah but
yeah
i
my agent was once on a plane and
uh was sitting next to a guy and was
like
you look like this obscure character
actor so and so that's sort of like this
has been from the 80s do people ever say
to that and i can't wish i remember who
was but it was someone very obscure and
the guy was like i am that person that
he was literally sitting next to this
guy we thought was a doppelganger and
just basically [ __ ] all over him as the
warm-up line
and i just love the premise of that
moment because you are then stuck next
to them for the you know the although
although
my agent richard is such a like charming
dude that i'm sure he out maneuvered
that awkward moment immediately and they
were best friends by the time the flight
landed but
representing him by the time they landed
right like taking over yeah he's like i
literally only represent composers but
i'm going to make an exception for you
yeah yeah well i i i
would like for you
troy to see
spider-man because i'm going to he was
so very funny and very sweet a few very
specific things that they did in that
film also that i was so impressed by
that i was like man that that they they
really uh
yeah i you know you'd think i i i keep
coming to this conclusion like
the mcu probably should have ended with
end game and then they just kind of like
reboot into something new or because it
just felt like
you know where you can't it's like it's
like ordering movies in you know it's
it's well no it was like ordering
dessert after you had sex in the
bathroom of the restaurant you had
dinner at
is apparently just like that i was gonna
go for yeah yeah yeah probably should
have just just right here
but let's go ahead and dessert i guess
it's like well we already set it up
we already ordered it
yeah there you go
that's all your point is i'll sin they
kind of surpasses that they kind of yeah
they managed to surprise the dessert
tastes really good in the restaurant
they they they
managed to do things with it and not the
obvious stuff like yes it's fun the the
things that they did that are the
obvious things that people get excited
about were were great and i had no but
you saw that coming but it was the it
was there was a few unexpected things
that i thought wow they really
again i don't want to i don't want to
get into it until i can speak more
openly about it so yeah i encourage you
to check it out uh but uh it's
phenomenally well written like to an
extent i was shocked by like exactly
it's really funny really sweet and again
i just
maybe we should also edit out the fact
that i talked about them
in the bathroom or the restaurant in
dessert
troy is that worse is that worse than
the hot cousin though i feel like i feel
like you've no no no yeah
that's what's weird is it was my cousin
granny's birthday my mom that's what you
headed out you edit that
out i'm so glad i can trust you guys
[Laughter]
i wanted to give a very quick shout out
to unpacking um really really wonderful
game that has such a unique approach to
storytelling i could not believe that a
game where you put items in a house got
so emotional is really cool um and my
most heartfelt game of the year has been
halo infinite which is also cheating uh
but it's just it's just because i'm
playing halo with all my friends all the
time again like i'm a teenager and it
rules that's what halo was all about
though
halo was all about bringing people
together i think it's it's a return i
didn't like the single player campaign
stuff i was like it was fun i played the
[ __ ] out of it but i i i actually
touched the single player campaign
halo is all about multiplayer it's all
about your friends and it's awesome
warthogging and stuff like that
i have to share the uh halo musical that
i did with tripod uh with you about
fantastic yeah it's like an eight it's
like an eight minute song about three
seconds of gameplay in blood gulch um
nice it's so
uh like god they're so good it's so
funny
um
but only the second best australians
frequently referenced on this podcast
though so
the second best australians
yes yeah fair that's fine
they are collectively one unit of an
australian what is the height what is
the hierarchy of australians
[Music]
hugh jackman's pretty high
yeah
[Music]
um we'll get into that next week um
rather than talking about spider-man
naturally but i did also want to say
happy new year everybody this episode
goes up on the 31st so i hope you all
have
a wonderful new year and we'll see 2022
don't be stupid
call your mother
always
that's all i got
yeah and that's it we'll see y'all next
week hell of an outro bye